come out of the second one tell a teen
Alvin platino Santos Alateen and famous
moussaka el mensaje CC Bravo kilo meter
admirable
we're in vallata refugee camp which is
the most densely populated camp in the
occupied West Bank this is also another
Street you things the crazy thing is you
would think that a refugee camp would be
a temporary type of thing but as you're
seeing these are generations growing up
here
born and raised so his family was exiled
there became refugees from Jaffa in 1948
they came here in 1950 and they've been
here ever since and no issue Jana dime
permanent beam cannon is rural museum
but in the Madame la colina a mechanical
aina and Nevada and Huckle out there
animal diamond in the mission Islam in
Moo hey Monroe Harlem ask an attorney no
job at all IFR art no a llama can't see
the invalid fee and in tamanna be hella
busy the Madonna lastly here visually a
from here from Africa of the 2000 are
being misled in Oakland no first name
cool no hugs are butterflies member
keironb a lot our Hospital Mike and
Danny Anna authority mechanic technical
office in Manhattan McKenna
talent out there Anna banana : knock
knock louder a kid and he had the Helena
not Robina hi deletion or hostile all
day lever deal and oh you know Anna
Minnie a philosopher Johnny affairs an
immersion can dip near job you can happy
the person whom she had irminsul a
listener he Rosa hey equally Vikram
Suhani patent business into sea otter
pop on this is like you know food trucks
this is like food car something filling
cooler southern corn with some spices
let's go on Sue's home
gianni mota Carla you know in term a new
actor is Technorati on a secret dance a
year closer to death can be who logic
mini affair no I'm dr. Walton a moon
connector ish horn
primo I am the morbid octoman 16 sauna
to connect a pioneer Barbara Bailey had
a circuit containing condition poker a
kid in Mobile yo Mulaney
he had a talisman advocacy mujer que la
que la gente faker as I know Hakone
allahumma Kaname Tamland in Oaxaca gnar
Toby Toby hotel oh no Emily no mira el
caminito a clue ha annum AHA an assessee
yama sorry over school and home Yannick
Machado hey caballo Milania stop oh oh
my pleasure
Janna amino analyze and measure and so
in cho la hora